>>> OH, JUST LIKE THAT.
PUSH IT UP.
YES, GORGEOUS, GIRL.
>> HOLD ON, DANTE.
CAN WE STOP?
>> WHAT'S WRONG, RU.
>> YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
>> I KNOW I DO, BUT ME ON
ANOTHER COVER OF DRAG MAGAZINE?
>> I MEAN, IT'S REDUNDANT.
>> WHO ELSE WOULD IT BE, GIRL?
YOU ARE DRAG.
>> I MEAN, THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WHERE'S THE NEXT GENERATION.
DRAG NEEDS SOMEONE NEW.
SOMEONE LIKE -- LIKE THAT.
WHO ARE YOU?
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
>> EVERYONE, TAKE FIVE.
LEAVE ME WITH THE FUTURE OF
DRAG.
>> OKAY, I GUESS WE'RE TAKING
FIVE.
>> THAT FACE.
THOSE CHEEKBONES.
THESE EYES.
THERE'S SOMETHING DYNAMIC ABOUT
YOU, BOY.
HAVE YOU EVER DONE DRAG?
>> NO, JUST WEED AND PILLS.
>> THERE'S A QUEEN INSIDE OF
YOU.
ALL SHE NEEDS IS A CROWN.
GET MY GIST?
>> HA.
>> JUST ONE, THE TUCK.
NO BALLS, NO BUMP.
THE JUNK GOES IN THE TRUNK.
>> OH, YOU NEED TO TAKE IT DOWN
AND BACK, NOT UP AND FRONT.
>> THAT SAID, YOU HAVE A
MAGNIFICENT PENIS.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> NOW, TWO, THE LOOK?
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> GAY.
>> PERFECT.
>> THE LOOK ISN'T COMPLETE
WITHOUT THE --
>> LEAVE THE CHICKEN CUTLETS
ALONE, YOU'RE GOING TO POP YOUR
TUCK.
>> OKAY.
>> WE NEED TO BEAT YOUR FACE FOR
THE GODS.
STEP THREE, THE FACE.
MAY I?
>> OKAY.
>> OH, CHILD, THAT IS DEFINITELY
YOUR COLOR.
POP YOUR LIPS LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO KISS.
>> NO, NO, NO.
CHAD, DARLING, I'M A MARRIED
MAN.
>> YOU'RE A MAN?
>> DID YOU NOT KNOW THAT?
>> NO.
>> THE LOOK IS ONLY HALF THE
BATTLE, NOW YOU NEED TO OWN IT.
BABY, IT IS TIME TO FEEL THE
FANTASY, LIKE THIS.
>> STROLL DOWN THE RUNWAY.
ANOTHER PAYDAY.
COVER OF MAGAZINES.
NOW, YOUR TURN, FIND A SONG THAT
SPEAKS TO THE NEW YOU.
YOU KNOW, THE QUEEN THAT YOU
REALLY ARE.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR YOU TO LIP
SYNC FOR YOUR LIFE.
>> OKAY.
♪♪♪
>> WORK IT, GIRL.
OH, YOU GONNA DO THAT.
YOU'RE A GODDESS.
HANDS ACROSS THE BOARD.
NOW, LET ME SEE YOU DO THAT
WALK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH!
MY GOODNESS, ARE YOU OKAY?
>> ALL GOOD.
>> CHAD, NO, THAT WASN'T GOOD,
HONEY, LOOK, I CAN MOLD YOU INTO
THE NEXT RuPAUL AND IF YOU WANT
TO BE THE BEST, YOU GOT TO BE
WILLING TO WORK YOUR PADDED ASS
OFF.
SO I'LL ASK YOU ONE MORE TIME,
DO YOU WANT TO BE THE GREATEST
DRAG QUEEN IN THE WORLD?
>> NO.
>> THEN YOU SHOULD TURN AND WALK
AWAY.
>> OKAY.
BYE, RUPUL.
>> CAN I GO?
>> SHHHH.
SOME HORSES WERE BORN TO RUN
WILD.
♪♪♪